my name is mandana i'm from iran
and i
am born in tehran and i grew up there
i lived there for 22 years and then i
moved to montreal
my research is about the role of memory
in reinforcement learning
and how that can improve the
computational efficiency of algorithms
basically i study how a memory mechanism
in human can advance rl algorithms
to solve real-world problems
so more specifically i study
representation and abstraction learned
by these models
and i work on a principal approach to
learn how we can improve the
computational efficiency of
reinforcement algorithms
by getting inspiration from human memory
it's not really a single person
and
it changes through time depending on a
project that i'm working on
um
but
yeah there are a lot of people who i try
to follow their works it's not just one
person
[Music]
i first did an internship at mila and
i spent almost six months here
and then i started to know the people
the student life at mila and i realized
that the research interests of a lot of
people here are
greatly aligned with mine and that was a
great motivation for me to start my phd
right after
and also i really like montreal so i'm
living here for almost five years
and i think it's a great city for
students if they want to spend their
time and just meet new people
and it has a great multicultural living
environment that i quite appreciate
enjoy the learning process
as much as the outcome so
don't just try to make great results
even though that is that's perfect but
also try to
learn
as much as you can when you are making
progress and i'd say the journey matters
as much as the destination
[Music]